i need you to help me in the kitchen we
got to finish this first gloria the
kid's never seen miracle on 34th street
that's because he always spends
christmas in colombia with my family and
all we see there is salazar and loso
save christmas sounds like a classic it
is mom can we finish the movie okay
he's not like anyone else he must be
santa
i think perhaps you're right suzie
[Laughter]
[Music]
he told me we were going to watch this
movie i got a joke copy from the
internet you are the innocent there well
maybe i'm a little confused right now
what is this innocente stuff in colombia
practical jokes are a christmas
tradition the one that is full is
dinosaunte we tell practical jokes on
april fool's day so do not do that again
[Laughter]
does it do it again ah it's ruined
okay
tonight nine o'clock sharp we open one
present each
pajamas which we sleep in tomorrow
morning 7 a.m manny on the stairs for
the christmas picture then
we open presents in colombia they open
presents at midnight and stay up till
morning i'm sure that they do but as
you'll notice from the absence of goats
in the street we are not in colombia
come on i'm kidding
why can't we mix a couple of colombian
traditions in like what like fireworks
come on you don't have fireworks in
colombia you're trying to make me the
innocente again no we do at night the
sky is beautiful very christmasy that
doesn't make any sense look every
country has their own traditions you
know culture for example the baby jesus
is the one that brings the gifts not the
santa claus but that doesn't make sense
how could a newborn baby carry all those
presents they don't even know where
their hands are at least a baby can fit
through a chimney how would you sit on
the baby jesus's lap you'd squish it
manny next year we'll talk about some of
your little colombian traditions okay
maybe i know what maybe means it's like
you're trying to take away my whole
christmas
okay now remind me we put this in the
oven first thing tomorrow cause jay
wants to eat at three o'clock hi manny
did you put this spider in the fridge oh
yeah
day
oh papi what's wrong i want to have
christmas like they do in colombia jay
is messing everything up and he tried to
understand
jay has great memories with his kids
when they were young and he just wants
to recreate them with you
so maybe the best gift i could give jay
would be christmas like he used to have
it
you're such a beautiful boy one day
you're gonna grow up and i'm gonna miss
all the things that you used to do as a
little boy
okay
but if this so-called santa claus
doesn't bring me a burgundy dinner
jacket i'm going to have a big problem
where are you for so long just a little
last-minute shopping uh
what's this
who what cheese fritters it's a
colombian traditional christmas food
okay new rule from now on we do
colombian things when we're in colombia
we do american things when we're in
america that means no more your food no
more your music and especially no more
your crazy holidays
did i say it wrong you two are totally
innocentes you should see the look on
your faces and by the way you know how
hard it is to get fireworks on christmas
eve
go money
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
you got me again
[Music]
you